okay hello and welcome to in the same
boat British and American visual culture
during the Second World War I'm dr. Eric
striker missing from SMU and one of the
co-chairs of the conference and I want
to just give you an introduction to some
of the themes and concepts that we hope
to become part of the discussion over
the next couple days the people of
Europe do not ask us to do their
fighting they ask us for the implements
of war planes guns tanks which enable
them to fight for their liberty and our
security we have furnished the British
with great material support and we will
furnish far more in the future in the
future Roosevelt you can always count on
Americans to do the right thing after
they've tried everything else Churchill
two voices to PO tations each with a
different valence Roosevelt's Stern
rally of American popular support
Churchill's comically underhanded praise
for his ally each became part of a
historical memory of the Second World
War by different means Roosevelt's
speech was distributed as a newsreel
securing itself in a securing itself a
place in the memory of historical
archives Churchill's quote is most
certainly apocryphal there's no known
record of his having spoken these words
or similar he didn't say it but perhaps
he should have instead they are part of
an oral tradition in the cultural memory
and legacy of the war but whose cultural
memory of the war exactly do we mean
does it represent a collective British
frustration with the American seeming
habit of entering Wars well just a
little bit late is it primarily a form
of kind hearted cross-culturally mockery
spoken by brits to the Yanks in social
gatherings is it as saying rehearsed by
American and British politicians or
diplomats as a means of encouraging
expedient policy decisions or does it
represent an American willingness to
joke about our own recidivist
isolationism while maintaining the myth
of American exceptionalism our basic
moral wrecked
wisdom and goodness despite our messy
Democratic lethargy in fact at least in
recent decades this last possibility
seems to be the most likely the quote
always attributed to Churchill has been
used on Capitol Hill and countless
public events and debates during the
2013 debt ceiling crisis for instance no
less than five congressmen and women
deployed it one of the most frenzied
instances of to borrow British ISM
Churchillian drift the gap between these
two acts of authorship as a fitting way
to introduce this conference we are
gathered to consider to the relationship
between visual production and the second
world war in two countries as most of
you no doubt aware we are convening
during the 70th anniversary of the e day
it is only fitting to take stock of our
dual cultural memories of those years
and benefit from seven decades of
critical hindsight in so doing however
we met all we must also contend with the
problem of deciphering layers of
authorship and audience consider words
for battle a Humphrey Jennings film
produced for the Ministry of
informations crown film unit in 1941 the
film rose from the recent British
documentary film movement it contains
rousing voiceovers by Laurence Olivier
resetting passages from British literary
greats Milton Blake browning Kipling
coupled with vast pastoral and aerial
views of that green and pleasant land
this material composes the near entirety
of the film with two critical exceptions
a nun complementary view of Hitler
ranting incomprehensibly and the film's
climax which is reserved for Abraham
Lincoln's Gettysburg Address Lincoln's
words are joined with his image a long
take of his likeness in Parliament
Square in London so then at the pinnacle
of a sequence of invigorating the
patriotic sound images of a proud
Britain one rooted in its landscape and
deep literary identity is poised Lincoln
that great Emancipator stepping off his
chair
as if to advise or perhaps even lend a
hand an image of American intervention
to them to be sure it is beyond doubt
that this film was aimed at a British
audience however the crown film unit
produced films that were intended both
for domestic audience and audiences
abroad to a popular American audience
the inclusion of Lincoln's words might
have been heard as an appeal to American
national pride a sense of moral duty to
intervene the memory of a just war
perhaps and no doubt a sense of two
nations with shared values indeed
stateside the film's majestic landscapes
and his gentle people may have even
worked as something akin to a military
recruitment technique I'll be at one
which barred from tourist advertising
however one can't help but to wonder
what valence this sequence might have
had to someone sitting in a cinema in a
British city where every day the skies
loom the technology where the axis
threat to national sovereignty is much
more of a present threat in every day
popular life and popular culture
certainly Lincoln would have been
understood as an icon of hope in which
America figures as not only ally ally
but Savior but at the same time the
self-sufficiency of the United Kingdom
and its geopolitical might was by then
inescapably in question the American
presence in the UK was a double-edged
sword foreshadowing the decline of
post-war Britain and his empire and the
ascendance of the u.s. into global
superpower a power that would in
instances like the Suez Canal crisis in
1956 tell Britain what it can and cannot
do in short even when even wear a visual
works are truly transatlantic in their
content or distribution we might wish to
resist completely emerging are two
national lenses let's keep in mind even
when allied political and military
efforts were strategically aligned
differences emerged famously the
competition some have said rancor
between Montgomery and patent for
example similarly we might wish to say
that American and British visual
material from the years 19 39 to 45 was
produced neither in perfect
collaboration nor perfect isolation but
rather in something of a vast ocean of
negotiation collaboration and difference
so then as we go about our collective
task of considering a great variety of
images and visual objects produced in
these years we are also asking
fundamental questions about the ontology
of images in military militarily
mobilized societies such works are often
though not always made with the dual
imperatives of topicality and mass
communication we must address how do
images speak about the war here the
benefit mystery of information seeking
to recruit the Empire behind it relies
on fizzy genomic typologies sent set
into a racial hierarchy for example also
who is due to speak doing the speaking
is it the photographer artist graphic
designer the publication the
commissioning body and here again the
Ministry of Information speaking to the
British public through an invented Nazi
alternate persona to whom are they
speaking American audience British
audience or both but also possibly an
access power in the case of Allied
propaganda misinformation campaigns and
psychological warfare campaigns such as
drops of allied periodicals including
American comic books over Germany and
elsewhere we must also ask ourselves how
well our visual message is heard across
an ocean of difference between dialects
across different media and within
divergent visual practices for instance
when we turn to art objects specifically
painting and sculpture we are presented
with possible failures of the
ideological lens which cannot quite rein
in perhaps a modernist abstraction
abstractions promise of universality
should make it universally legible and
yet a refusal of representation might
diminish topical relevance or even
subvert official messages so is
abstraction a reluctance to participate
in the war effort or is it diagrammatic
and therefore proximate to the
functional visuality of military
strategy and planning like aerial
photography or topographical maps or
hear a report on the damn Buster raids
from fort 1943 we also hope to locate
not only clear points of collaborative
or distinct visual cultures but also but
to question the significance of
ambiguity and ambivalence in such images
indeed that familiar phrase the fog of
war is an apt metaphor for the visual
landscape we are navigating where the
ideological lens of propaganda seeks
clear messages clear meanings and is
planned strategically before being if
you will deploy two armies of
photographers filmmakers artists
exhibition venues the view on the ground
is quite different the movement of
friends and foes becomes illegible and
here Paul Nash Paul Nash's Battle of
Britain as an example of this sort of
work the strategist bird's eye view
loses its practical value here
Motherwell's view from a high tower uses
amongst other things military maps as
part of a collage trickery sends false
messages here from the operation
bodyguard campaigns and sort of some
fields of false planes meant to deceive
where the the view from the air is quite
different as a false view from the view
on the ground the sort of true view the
subject position of the image maker
intervenes here Lee Miller is a good
example of this her personal narrative
is quite interesting as well as the sort
of a localization of surrealist ropes
into the real the encounter with the
other disrupts here on the left from
Time magazine three good hates an
example of artists one Japanese from
German want Italian being invited to
character access leaders but also
artists who were later classified as
enemy aliens of irony in that and that
story there or on the right the sort of
humanistic potentially humanistic
photograph of a young German soldier
outside the Battle of the Bulge
blackouts obscure visible identities and
here I'm using slightly cheating 1946
but nonetheless an example of a bill
brandt photo photograph in which fog
ambiguity darkness who could say a kind
of Charis curl in silhouette figures
seem to rely at the sort of
signification of direct identities so
perhaps the visual more than language is
especially open to misinterpretation
vagary duplicity ambivalence fog and
this is the unifying character of the
visual culture of the Anglophone allies
to borrow terms from Roland barks
rhetoric of the image war imagery seems
to so often want and find anchors and
relays but the nature of war produces
environments where visibility and
legibility are stretched to a breaking
point it's just interesting in examples
like these this from the convoys to
Malta that there's so much other anchor
and text to signify the meaning of an
image to to signify what that the
content is this brings us to the
conference's primary questions first can
we locate and define an origin of what
would later come to be called a special
relationship between Britain and America
in the visuality of the war do natural
allies
naturally similar visual culture during
a crisis and if there are marked
differences between them what brings
those differences about secondly can we
formulate a model for understanding how
the visual cultures of war relate to
reflect on wrestle with represent or
resonate with the actualities of war in
this age of total war here we must
address the real is the representation
of real events real conditions real
needs an inescapable political dictum
for image producers and who gets
determine gets to determine the reality
represented third how indeed how much do
we distinguish visual media from each
other in the degree to which they can be
mobilized for the war effort does the
very fact of mobilizing artists in all
media towards the war effort extinguish
a relevance of medium specificity and
finally how can we account for the role
of institutions governmental organs
artistic communities institutional
networks periodical publications in not
only shaping wartime visual production
according to the needs of the war effort
but also in providing alternative
discursive spaces of expression a ration
of food for thought as we venture
forward at this juncture I will hand
over to Tatiana one of the co-chairs for
the conference who will speak to you
about the conference backstory and
logistics so welcome
thank you your ex so much so the idea
for this conference was motivated by the
desire to visit the early 1940s and to
give texture to the period and
individual work artworks created at the
time primarily by initiating
conversations across geographic and
methodological divides within the world
with two scholarship all the world would
you have long been a neglected subject
in the historiography of both American
and British art with a few notable
exceptions including the scholarship by
our two key notes for the conference
there has recently been a resurgence of
interest in this period this past
februari a CA panel entitled new
genealogies of american modern azmuth
mid-century which was chaired by angela
miller and jody patterson provided a
much-needed forum for reconsidering of
the reflexive divide between pre and
post World War two culture in the United
States similarly the upcoming panel
entitled on the visual front revised in
World War two an American art shared by
John odd and Melissa ran that will take
place during the 2016 see a conference
it will certainly provide another
important intervention into the study of
the period in the context of American
visual culture on the other side of the
Atlantic we have experienced a wave of
interest in 20th century British art
history following on the foothills of
the victorious fascination with
modernity nevertheless here to our
historical research into the 1940s has
been slower to pick up the pace yet
things are changing after Pete Peters
stance Keys world with you in the Blitz
which was published quite some time ago
we now have Brian fauces warpaint are
dwarfs state and identity in Britain
1939-1945 Monica bomb do cheon's
recently published art and the Second
World War provides a compelling overview
of the visual production during World
with you across the border including
artistic responses to the war in Britain
and
in the United States this conference
then aims to provide a forum for a
variety of scholarly approaches to the
early 1940s the together acknowledged
the heterogeneity and complexity of the
period in question by focusing
specifically on the American and British
contacts we also hope to ship the access
of the scholarship on transatlantic and
trans cultural exchanges during the war
from a more established New York Paris
access to incorporate alternative
wartime geographies and modes of
artistic interchange so over the next
two days we'll have five panels total
three panels are scheduled for today and
then two for tomorrow Saturday there
will be two keynote addresses one on
friday evening at four-fifteen p.m. and
another on saturday afternoon at
eleven-fifteen am as well as the
screening of the canterbury tail on
saturday which will be followed by a
roundtable discussion we also hope that
you will be able to join us for a
reception tonight that will start at
five-thirty p.m. and it will take place
in the null drawing studio which is in
the basement of the Laureus Center so
this building here in the basement level
we are immensely grateful to all the
institutions organizations and
individuals who helped to make this
event a reality this conference is made
possible through support from the Darra
foundation for American art it is also
generously sponsored by the Yale
University Department of the history of
art the Yale Center for British art the
utter OG and Dorothy Clark cam from
Memorial Fund and the Whitney and Betty
McMullen a center for international and
era studies at Yale Eric and I would
both like to particularly think our co
chair sofa linford for her immense
contribution to the conference many of
you might have been in touch with her
already in preparation for the event and
you can attach to her incredible
attention to detail a stewed mind as
well as her thoughtful and good human
nature we are immeasurably grateful for
all her
hard work and valuable inside this
conference would not be possible without
the help consistent support guidance and
encouragement from team behringer paul
mellon professor of the history of art
at yale university professor Barringer's
own work and broad range and expertise
in the period served as an important
source of information and inspiration
while developing the concept for this
conference we would also like to thank
director of the Yale Center for British
art Emma Myers and dr. Martina draweth
the head of research as well as their
fantastic team for all the advice and
assistance on the conference the British
art center is currently closed for
renovations but it will reopen in spring
2016 with an exhibition of me 20th
century British artworks recently gifted
to the museum by Rhoda Pritzker we owe a
debt of gratitude to not cook Charles F
Montgomery a professor for support in
the conference from the very very
beginning and we are grateful to Nicole
short year the business manager of art
history department for all her hard work
on the logistical details for the
conference a big thanks to Victoria
Pierre who has been valuable in a system
with different stages of organizing and
coordinating this event we're also
grateful to Jennifer Rob assistant
professor in art history for helping
with chair in the afternoon panels as
well as to Katie Trump nur professor of
comparative literature in english and
Kirsty doutzen doctoral candidate in art
history and film studies for leading the
discussion after the film screening on
Saturday thank you to all the presenters
for sharing their work and ideas with us
over the next two days and thank you all
for coming and welcome
you